in every esport under the sun there are
selections that are considered
let's say
low tier and i i don't know if anyone is
going to disagree with me here just what
were they thinking with this guy only
the bravest most honorable and most
honest of souls are able to muster up
the courage to not only give such
selections a try but main them in the
highest levels of play you cannot
activate here if your motto jumped away
from the ex mono needs this the jump
finish
as he takes his upper punch
and in the cartoonish rainbow-filled
corridors of valerante where riot has
been known to allow agents of lesser
strength to be forgotten there is one
streamer who is quite literally leading
the charge when it comes to glorifying
one of the game's trolliest agents
i feel so bad for that chamber
meet alexander shiro rodriguez a meta
neglecting renegade whose dream was to
become valorance de facto neon main on
twitch i hope you enjoyed it
oh
my
god
[Applause]
so what made a once aspiring fortnite
and smash bros competitor wanna play
valorant like it's apex legends what
reasons outside of his control caused
him to abandon the games where he wanted
to make his name initially and why on
earth did he choose to build his entire
brand around what many consider to be
one of the game's worst agents
i keep doing it
okay so you know the drill please like
the video subscribe to the channel and
turn on notifications also if you are
another one of these crazy low-tier
loving psychopaths who we can make
another million view valor video about
make sure to dm me because we're uh
we're running out of one tricks to
exploit alright so before he began
terrorizing the valorant community with
his neon sliding shenanigans where
exactly did this chill 20 year old
content creator come from well shiro was
born and raised in southern california
and with a mexican father and nicaraguan
mother it didn't take long for him and
his brothers to get enrolled into soccer
i wasn't like actually in like one of
those like crazy leagues it was just one
of those like you know little kid
leagues and then i eventually i started
getting better and better
and there was like people that wanted to
like
grab me for teams but
i got into gaming and i just said
i didn't want to do that i didn't want
to play soccer anymore growing up with
two older brothers video games were
always easily accessible for shiro he
and his siblings spent countless hours
playing mario strikers and super smash
brothers melee together giving shiro his
first taste of competition and lord
knows he loved it when the xbox 360
released he eventually found himself
playing shooters like call of duty and
halo but when he caught his brother
playing a league of legends one
afternoon young shiro decided to make
the move from console to pc like most
newcomers to league
he had
absolutely no idea what he was doing he
kept playing of course and like most
experienced league players
continued to have absolutely no idea
what he was doing
all right i swear
i'm done
to be fair shiro was actually really
good he's only unforgivable sin was that
he was a
filthy yasmo main i'd actually just
write it down like i didn't care about i
didn't care about learning the game i
just i was just nuts mechanically on
yasuo i just run it down and fight
everyone after he grew tired of ruining
people's mentals in league shiro dumped
mobas altogether and joined his friends
who were hooked on cs go but right as he
was starting to climb the ranks valve
dropped the r8 update in december of
2015. many players noticed massive dips
in their game's performance and
unfortunately shiro was among those
affected i got into cs go
and i'll and that that's where i was
like really having fun with my friends i
got up to lem
but then like csgo came out with this
update that just the pc i had the time
was so bad
i got like 10 frames in a smoke and i
had to stop playing cs but as fate would
have it right as shiro's
counter-striking days were coming to an
unfortunate end
a new game launched that would soon
scratch his competitive itch
an elite international task force
charged with ending the war and
restoring liberty to all nations
overwatch
but overwatch wasn't just a competitive
outlet for shiro
it was a content driven one he enjoyed
playing it so much that it inspired both
him and his friend keo to dip their toes
into streaming shiro had been a long
time fan of both mango and tyler1 so at
every given opportunity he tried to
follow in their footsteps on twitch i'd
get on my brother's pc before he'd get
home from like school or work and i'd
just stream however long he i could and
he'd get home he'd be like all right
alex get off
come on and then and then i i'd get off
but i just love streaming i don't know i
get zero viewers but i just have so much
fun just just thinking about streaming
but when shiro wasn't able to get on his
brother's pc he was still committing a
lot of his time to playing melee he even
considered going pro but with so many
obstacles in his way he opted to focus
his attention instead on streaming
we're not even there
it was fast
though oh
holy oh
now while shiro's affinity and
enthusiasm for streaming was steadily on
the rise the same couldn't exactly be
said for that of his parents and my dad
you know he thought i was wasting my
time playing video games like every time
he'd see me on he'd just be like oh
you're wasting your time playing video
games i mean it makes sense having two
immigrant parents
they're not gonna know what
streaming is or what it could do and
they're still old school you got to go
to school you got to
get a degree you got to get a job
despite the lack of optimism at home
about his twitch career shiro kept at it
because he truly believed that one day
he could make it big but once again
right ashiro was building momentum in a
game he genuinely adored
fate intervened you see shiro had been
streaming overwatch for years as a
tracer main but when blizzard introduced
brigitta in march of 2018 a move that
essentially ruined the game for dps
players he decided that once again it
was time to move on fortunately for
shiro at that time the streaming world
was being taken over by a battle royale
craze but the one that caught his
attention the most was fortnite fortnite
was a perfect fit for shiro it was fun
streamer friendly but also mechanically
demanding enough that it could catch and
keep the attention of such a cracked
egamer
all right this is for you ditzy
what the [__]
but beyond the highlights that he was
regularly able to produce playing
fortnite the game also gave him a taste
of one of the great perks of being a
self-employed content creator
a paycheck
yeah once i started making that money
from fortnite and the stream revenue
came in it was like 100 something bucks
at the time but i was in high school
making money from gaming i was like dude
like this is sick like all my friends
would be like you're putting so many
hours into that you're only getting 100
bucks i'm like dude
it's so fun fortnite also offered shiro
a competitive scene to test his skills
against some of the best players in the
world which was something that had
always interested him but while he was
able to hit top 50 in qualifiers for the
fortnite world cup on multiple occasions
every time he came close to qualifying
for the main event he would choke of
course that didn't matter because
unfortunately for shiro epic games
eventually decided that it was time to
add mechs to fortnite chocolate
chocolate i'm talking [__] with me
let's go let's go let's go
oh my
god dude there's no way
this is literally in the game
now if you've been paying attention up
until this point you've probably noticed
that there's sort of a trend with shiro
the dude falls in love with the game
throws himself into it and then watches
as it essentially gets ruined by the
developers but in april of 2020 when
riot games released the beta for its
much anticipated attack shooter valorant
shiro saw an opportunity and dived in
immediately with gun mechanics that
paralleled counter-strike and agent
abilities that pulled from both
overwatch and league of legends valorent
was the perfect blend of some of shiro's
favorite games from his teenage years
shiro took to valorant like a duck to
water and while he initially entertained
the idea of going pro once his
viewership started to ramp up he decided
against it there's nothing better than
competing for me like i love competing
but the thing is
is that if i actually wanted to compete
and go pro i'd have to drop
like
so much stream and content christian
time
and
it's just not it's just not worth it
because i've already built up to this
point but in an effort to keep his
content unique shiro decided that if he
was going to play valorant he was only
going to play the agents that were
widely considered
to be
awful and it may come as a surprise to
many of you who weren't around back in
the closed beta but back then jet was
actually considered to be one of those
agents although
you wouldn't have guessed it watching
shiro play her
down
one enemy
i'm the best in the world
from that point on shiro made it his
mission to only maine the game's
shittiest agents he moved from jet to
yoru then briefly tried chamber before
realizing that he was way
way too overpowered for him it wasn't
until january of 2022 that shiro finally
found the trash tier agent that he would
eventually build his entire brand around
welcome neon we are thankful that your
path has led you here
now when neon came out the general
consensus was that she was just another
weak agent but with her sprinting and
sliding ability she was unique and
offered plenty of outplay potential so
shiro was determined to learn everything
he could about her i always just play
whatever fits my playstyle whatever i
enjoy playing in every game i've picked
a character that's like fast paced if
that makes sense and neon was just
exactly that
one enemy remaining
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my
thanks to shiro's unholy matrimony with
neon his twitch and youtube channels
began to see a noticeable bump in
traffic and his audience wasn't just
returning because he was challenging
people's perception of the agent they
were coming back
because of him after years of tirelessly
sowing his streaming seeds shiro was
finally starting to enjoy a taste of the
success he had dreamed of all along but
with that triumph came a difficult
decision you see at the time shiro was
attending california state university
fullerton for a visual arts degree and
he was already set to start his third
year of the program drawing and digital
art had always been one of his hobbies
but becoming a full-time streamer was
his dream so he decided to take a
semester off of college to pursue it
with his immediate future decided shiro
continued to grind away with neon to
prove that she was viable in ranked
convincing his teammates that he wasn't
just trolling though was a different
kind of challenge i think i think he was
locking neon before like a lot of people
were locking neon and i was just like
why is there a neon in my game
like what does this mean like what what
what am i playing today what is this
game gonna be you know it's definitely
not gonna be normal the the trash agents
where people are like dude you're
throwing playing this character
and then and just making them seem so
good
and then and then shutting everyone up
it's just so fun
only jar
but while shiro was trying to get some
respect put on neon's name in
matchmaking optic gaming was furthering
that effort at valorant masters in
reykjavik not many agents can make space
and play such a hyper aggressive
playstyle the way that neon can and
optic's willingness to incorporate her
into their play was a huge reason why
they were able to take home the masters
one title seeing neon in pro play was
like dude everyone's gonna start playing
neon now
like that was my first thought i did i
didn't really care but it was it was
really cool to see what those guys are
doing on neon like they're
taking it to the highest level of the
game and and i was i was watching like
victor some of the site takes he would
do i was like dude like
i do the same stuff like that's why neon
is so good
and he's he's stunning whole sites and
taking with his wall and just creating
so much space there's no way people are
still gonna think neon's a bad agent now
and it's it's gone a lot better for me i
don't really get flamed as much for
picking neon it's like people actually
acknowledge her as a good pick now in
the highest level and while it was nice
seeing neon up on the big stage it
did sort of screw shiro over because
almost immediately after the event riot
pushed some neon nerfs that nobody
really expected to see changes that made
her energy drain much faster and caused
her wall to no longer do any sort of
damage and considering most of the
community regarded her as a low tier to
begin with
people were sort of confused as to why
riot would opt to nerf her
especially shiro it was it just felt so
weird to wake up to neon nerfs
she just feels
pretty weak in
certain scenarios where like i said like
she was strong before like
i used to throw a wall and be able to
stall pushes because they were scared of
the wall damage
it was a great utility
to do damage to people and to just like
put fear into swinging her wall as well
like imagine you're one hp and you swing
a wall now you can like get three people
out of it if you're like
if you're just crazy enough despite the
nerfs shiro continued to prove that this
slippery apex legends looking agent does
in fact have a place within a slow
methodical tax shooter she's still the
only agent he plays and his growth on
twitch is in large part thanks to his
mastery of her a mastery that he has
since shared with his audience on
youtube in the form of a pretty
comprehensive guy but luckily for shiro
riot recently decided to show some love
to neon adding a three times multiplier
to her headshots while using her
ultimate dude that headshot multiplier
is so crazy yesterday i hopped on i
popped my all and like basically one
click like one tap people it's crazy i
love it it's it makes her so much more
skillful
and it makes her all actually like
viable
in uh in these high elo lobbies at the
end of the day there's no denying that
shiro's path towards becoming a
full-time content creator
hasn't always been clear-cut but through
circumstances outside of his own control
he's found his calling with not only
valorant but an agent that nobody could
have cared less about and thanks to neon
and his own determination to play the
game the way he wants shiro is finally
able to pursue his dreams
one colorful chaotic slide at a time
there's something about
dreaming i've always enjoyed that and
then
there's always been this belief in
myself that i could i could do it like i
i don't know i just it's been what five
years now and
there's been a surge of success that
i've had
and still it's nowhere near what i'm
probably
gonna be at like i just think i'm gonna
keep growing
i made a great joke here in miles cut it
it cuts to me being on the on cam being
like wait shouldn't i say football
so we don't piss off the european fans
and then we do and then we no no and
then we do a punch in and i go oh wait a
minute there are no european fans
watching a valor video
what am i saying
no need